hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to The Escapist 2 now
I'm doing well so far not great but hey
I haven't been caught I've only got a
little bit of notoriety and everything
seems to be okay
got to find a makeshift beer and I've
got to get out of this goddamn place
before everybody kills me but hey that's
just the way this life works in it so I
don't know where I'm gonna find a
makeshift spear other than buying it I
don't know but I got a makeshift spear
got a spear
anybody got a spear no but you got the
components for Spears jeez
alright I've been here roll call can I
leave now can I leave I'm here I've been
here have done this go now please
oh dude are gonna get searched
hopefully I don't get searched but
chances are rare so what are the odds
that's gonna happen I just got to make
an appearance here I don't actually have
to do anything okay let's see what we
got in the way of crafting we've
unlocked ooh ooh I'm a chips beer I can
make that if I had a stick which I don't
have I guess I could break a broom
handle to get that we're out of here oh
yes please
I'm so full all right put it away no way
how do I put it away no no put it how do
I put it away oh god I forgot now to put
how do I put it away ah okay there we go
good god ah it's such a pain in the
douche all right
either way we got free time now so let's
go make the best of it by looting other
people's stuff all right so let's take
another scout around because there's a
lot of stuff here okay so parking lot
over there walls are over there there's
a main parking lot over there but
getting through there is gonna be yeah
probably the son of a [ __ ] oh wait is
there already oh my god there's already
a makeshift spear in here just ready to
go nowhere what are you talking about I
just have a makeshift spear that's so
cool
so it just it creates objectives that it
can you can actually accomplish instead
of having to go through the arduous
process of getting it oh well I got this
guy a spear then so that's good oh I
gotta go upstairs and the diamond
minecraft manicure kid
all right cheer I'll get you that later
nerd just one more for a day at the spa
which honestly is kind of nice if all
the things that people have been able to
want me to get it's better than a
makeshift spear just give them a nice
relaxing day at this spa
oh don't come this way no I wasn't doing
anything in there you didn't see nothing
no God he went in there okay I don't got
nothing I don't got nothing
oh I got a craft a manicure kit oh oh
that's what I gotta do
I gotta get to my job soon but right now
a manicure kit that's nice oh I got it
officer banheart where you at you
scoundrel I've got a good thing for you
I'm shifting it Lord can I shift it I'm
trying to deliver officer there you go
you got it you got it buddy I'm getting
to move on but just so you know I love
you love you very much you're my pride
and joy
I'm not late I'm not late I'm not late
I'm not late I'm not late I'm not lay
I'm not late I got a lot of suspicion
but I'm not late not late not late not
late night late not late give me money I
don't want a job but give me morning
[Music]
Fanta turn out the cooking you've been
going through you bore me ah you haven't
listened to a word I said go on Gil I've
listened I listen don't give up on me I
won't give up on you so it looks like my
best bet is gonna be going through the
South Area but I'm gonna need a lot of
materials to be able to do that I am I
am
wham bam okay oh yeah that was good
stuff what do you got Linds
plan to spend cover sure why not let me
get somewhat of a shower and then I
gotta get moving on plant this vent
cover is apparently that's something
that you just have done all right that's
easy yeah these are easy all right but
how much money do I have is a question
still got that makeshift spear because I
didn't actually deliver to the person
flood Dan the diamond minecraft stylet
isn't he gonna do that on his own
sorry dad just walk right in there
without you even thinking about it well
officer hood you have a good day okay
goodbye
flush I don't have anything flush what
do i flush down their toilet plepper
sugar cubes toothpaste that'll do
that'll do that'll do Pig why ah nice
okay so second day relatively uneventful
because I was just preparing I have to
get this stuff to craft more things but
it's really nice because some of these
quests actually get me to the place I
need to go with that so once I get there
I'll be able to do more but until then I
got to play the fool all right good
there I'm gonna find the baseball mitt
and then I'm good to go on that front
then I'm gonna start trying to find the
materials I need to be able to build
what I need to build it J [ __ ] man J
whoa like oh I didn't get that I thought
I got that oh he was unconscious I
thought I got that that that officer was
unconscious ah bull honky all right
Leslie Leslie put you up this i'ma stab
this [ __ ] out of him all right who needs
to be put down I've got me uh I've got
me something for whooping I've got a
bunch of um pitched about to be
delivered to your head with a spear that
could kill someone couldn't it seems
like that could kill somebody
yeah I deal with my fists here comes the
power track whoa that was a charge yeah
I smell a trap whoa
you ready Leslie you I don't think you
are whoopsies well Leslie here comes
under first oh that's an interesting
attack
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
gotcha
Oh box maybe I can smash up the old box
you didn't see nothin I saw nothing you
saw nothing definitely I just beat the
[ __ ] out of him what do I do with this
old box ah I stole your [ __ ] stole your
[ __ ] I'm not stealing anybody's [ __ ]
that's for damn sure
steal your [ __ ] your [ __ ] I'll stow your
[ __ ] ah I stole your [ __ ] I'm about to
make the most unbelievable contraband
this world has ever known
I'm gonna make a goddamn bed dummy give
me a goddamn bad dummy now Oh two
pillows it's got to be super comfy I
forgot about that
alright now we're gonna make a goddamn
bed dummy it's gonna be super comfy
you're gonna see crapped it up there we
go alright now I'm gonna put that in the
contraband ah alright so we got our
bread dummy so that at night we can do
some stool it's almost again a free time
here it's gonna be lunchtime and I want
to miss lunchtime we just do like
lunchtime lunch times good lunchtime is
fun time as I always say lunch time fun
time that's how it goes ah yeah the
spoons I forgot about the spoons don't
get a bunch of spoons spoons ain't gonna
be very good I know spoons ain't good
but spoons spoons or spoons you know
sponge of spoons that's what my daddy
always debate spoons or spoons damn this
spoon is not gonna do this a lot of good
I forgot how bad spoons actually were so
maybe that's not the best course of
action watch out guys I got my spoon
guys see my spoon
you see miss why is that guy was the guy
in a construction out with exercise time
that don't make no sense a dead rat I
gotta put a dead rat in Frankie's desk
yeah that's horrible why would I do that
I want to do that I mean I'll do it but
I'm not gonna be happy about it okay put
a dead rat there don't know why I did
that but it did it Oh information is
these are the hints right forget about
that
[Music]
I'm hoping someone got something good at
this roll call cuz I'm gonna be looking
cuz I got a lot of gold do I have a lot
of gold yeah I got two hundred fifty
five money so I gotta use it there there
we go I need tool handle that's what I
need I need tool annals to be able to
build more tools yeah that's the goods
ooh
contraband pouch is also good I want to
get that contraband pouch there's
another tool apply that
what does that do for me that add to my
inventory or something why I bought it
where'd it go what what oh is this part
of the bait I was broken why didn't do
that that was not me I was innocent and
he hit me first no don't get me nothing
about me need nothing to nobody
fine so I'm going to actually stay up
tonight nice they'll never know he I'm
sleep slopping I'm sleep slurping don't
mind me all right so I'm gonna take the
screwdriver I'm gonna put this Oh
screwdriver can actually break down this
wall I highly doubt that but alright
whatever whatever you saying okay so the
it's up here if I pick this up here jump
up there nope one over whoop oh no don't
open it
[Music]
come on keep going keep going keep going
oh yeah oh yeah that's the good stuff
oh now we're getting somewhere ah now
we're getting somewhere
take that okay all right then who's that
guy coming over here wouldn't matter
right up up on the thing in here up on
the thing in here okay
so we're up so let's just see where this
leads
I doubt any event sir just gonna go
outside that would be stupid so all the
vents go to the other places that vent
goes to the library no good to know good
to know these go nowhere as they should
I wouldn't expect them to go anywhere
really but I could get out of my cell by
going through here and just dropping
down if I was able to avoid the patrols
that is something that I could do it is
an option ooh
where does that drop off that looks like
a drop-off that might be a bit farther
forward it might be a good idea but I
don't think I have time to do it tonight
I'm just gonna rest and I'll hit it
tomorrow but I got I got I got a little
bit of a start here get rid of some of
these [ __ ] oh I hope they don't find
anything of mine I've got a lot of crap
here I whatever I just gotta go I'm
picking up my pace my pace is has picked
he's gonna get 75 gold whoa energy
module paperclip roll a duct tape
okay I don't know what you want me to do
but I'm sorry I got damn it I did it
again
what did I do I hit I why does I Oh eyes
hit I thought I was inventory for some
stupid reason energy module I don't know
who just left an energy module lying
about but that's pretty convenient for
me I don't even know what it good what
are you doing no no the duct tape did
you find the duct tape all this needs
reporting Oh
what did I do damage to the bra oh
that's not good
that dog you wanted a piece of me you
sheesh I forgot to put the the vent
cover back on I guess or they found that
the bullet oh boy no no no no no no no
no oh god I was just doing that for fun
z onesies I wasn't actually doing
nothing well that's no good but that's
alright I'm just gonna go get the duct
tape now oh why is it it it's an
evidence Locker
it's just duct tape
I have duct tape I don't need that duct
tape do i Oh pish-posh
bark bark Oh Frick seasons you guys suck
you guys suck
move this one again it's my first time
oh it was incredibly difficult all right
I will okay anyway so that's all the
time I got for this episode of escapist
this is quite difficult but I can do
this I think anyway I think again
therefore I can write that's how it
works all right whatever I'm off than
Adam so thank you everybody so much for
watching in the next episode I guarantee
I will be is copied from this place no
matter what so thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]